bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france en direct alors que symbolise la
à basilique sainte sophie et bien la
sainte sophie et et une est un monument
en réalité bien sûr construite par l
empire romain est par la suite devenu le
symbole de à l'apport de la chrétienté
orientale mais surtout ça ne se fient et
un est un monument qui véritablement
commun à toute la civilisation humaine
les ottomans et l'ont transformé certes
en mosquée mais en réalité elles n'ont
jamais véritablement au début supprimer
tous les symboles tous les éléments en
fait de du début par ailleurs sanofi en
fait est entré dans la légende en fait
du monde musulman également et nous
avons un très grand nombre de légendes à
la fois de l'accord de la construction
nous sommes surpris mais aussi de la
fondation de constantinople par
conséquent celle se fit créer un lien
extrêmement solide entre l'orient et
l'occident et par conséquent il ne faut
surtout pas à mon sens attribué
uniquement à un côté comme à l'autre est
ce qu'à travers cette transformation a
décidé à part le président turc et il ya
une certaine nostalgie de l'empiré
ottoman il est évident que la
transformation de la mosquée ne
correspond absolument rien aucun besoin
en fait dire de la nécessité en fait de
lieux de culte est acceptable puisque
autour de sa sortie il ya de très
nombreuses mosquées d'ailleurs la
population
j'allais dire de démocrates de gauche
ont bien souligner en fait cette la
présence enfin de très grand nombre de
mosquées le président lui même lorsqu'il
était à farouchement opposés à la
transformation de ce monument en mosquée
lui même il est dit ou de le retrouver
en direct d'entre deux trains de
l'occasion pour dire que personne ne
pourrait me dire que la transformation
de la scène se fier aux mosquées
correspond à une nécessité
par contre cette transformation
corresponde véritablement à une
nécessité politique est conjoncturelle
en fait du pouvoir en place puisque
visiblement ce pouvoir est en train de
se craqueler de partout dans tous les
sens du terme et notamment
économiquement et politiquement
il fallait donc trouver probablement un
symbole puissant alors justement est ce
que est ce que cette transformation
était une demande de la population
turque erdogan at il agi de cette
manière pour satisfaire son électorat
sur l'électorat de base assez restreint
de certes mais la majorité en bon en
fait ces deux mois n'est absolument pas
n'émane pas du tout de la population en
général
il dit même on rit semblerait même que
ça soit la toute dernière branche en
fête à laquelle le pouvoir en place
s'accordent eux s'accrochent pour
maintenir éventuellement une comment
dire une possibilité de réélection du
président en 2023 mais là jusqu'à là
nous avons en fait beaucoup de temps il
est possible qu'en fait même même cette
sortie en fait ne puisse pas le le
sauver disons ça suffit
probablement pour moi en tout cas devait
rester un symbole en fait de monuments
universel pour tout le monde
bon il se trouve que là le pouvoir en
place est élu démocratiquement certes
représentant une majorité est bien de
transformer bon nous attendons
maintenant sur tout
la suite parce que quid en fait de grâce
à sophie en tant que lieu de visite et
surtout en tant que maintient en fait de
très grand nombre de symboles et de
monuments à l'intérieur de celle sophie
puisque nous en tant que l'historial
nous visitions en fait alors je vais
dire mais chaque fois qu'on le voulait
maintenant est-ce qu'on pourrait la
visiter ce facilement est ce que la
direction des affaires religieuses va
permettre de faire de recherche de
façons de façon libre un signal un
signal qui est clairement envoyé aux
occidentaux avec cette transformation
est ce que également c'est un nouveau
pas pour un état turc toujours moins
laïque
c'est un nouveau pas pour encore une
fois se distancier se différencier en
fait du monde occidental
c'est une question en fait presque 2
j'allais dire de revanche sur l'histoire
c'est tout là une relecture en fait du
monde ottoman et aussi pour la une
revendication une prétention est on va
dire de ceux s'inscrire dans la lignée
de l'environnement par le président est
bonne et même on va surtout le dire en
fait de mise à l'écart dans fait du
kémalisme qui représente évidemment la
laïcité la démocratie l'ouverture vers
l'occident
et c'est une une revanche sur l'histoire
longue et l'histoire courte on va dire
merci beaucoup faruk bilici d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france
rappelle que vous êtes historien de la
turquie contemporaine